WASHINGTON AND SAID START
OVER BECAUSE YOU'RE
PERPETUATING A FRAUD ON THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
DAVE, I WANT TO GET YOUR
THOUGHTS ON THE TRANSGENDER
TROOP BAN AS WELL.
>> YOU KNOW, ABSOLUTELY.
YOU ARE RIGHT.
IT'S A FALSE CHOICE.
YOU CAN DO THE MILITARY AND
GET THE GOODLATTE BILL IN,
RIGHT?
THAT'S THE FUNDAMENTAL PIECE
ON IMMIGRATION WHICH IS
POLLING HIGHER THAN
OBAMACARE FOR REPUBLICANS.
WE FAILED ON THE PREMIER
PIECE THAT HE RAN ON AND
THAT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
WANT, WAGES HAVE BEEN FLAT
FOR 30 YEARS.
AND EVERYONE FROM BERNIE
THROUGH PRESIDENT TRUMP
WANTS TO FIX THE MESS IN THE
SWAMP.
AND I COULD HAVE JUST COME
BACK TO TOWN AND SAID LET'S
DO TWO WEEK CR AND MADE SOME
MAJOR MOVES.
>> Laura: IT WOULD HAVE BEEN
GUTSY.
>> THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN
THAT'S HIS STRENGTH.
HE HAS A GOOD GUT FOR IT.
>> Laura: AT LEAST WE GET
$1.7 BILLION A YEAR TO
MAINTAIN 770,000 EMPTY
BUILDINGS, SQUARE FEET OF
EMPTY BUILDING OFFICE SPACE.
OKAY.
SO THIS IS WHAT WE -- WE GOT
THAT MONEY.
I WANT TO TALK BRIEFLY ABOUT
THIS TRANSGENDER TROOP BAN.
THE LEFT IS GOING TO GO
CRAZY ON THIS ALL WEEKEND
LONG INTO EARLY NEXT WEEK
AND CONGRESSMAN,
COMMONWEALTH OF VIRGINIA.
BIG MILITARY STATE.
THIS WAS TAKEN AFTER SOME
CONCERTED STUD I DON'T KNOW
00 ISSUE.
THE STATEMENT OF THE WHITE
HOUSE TODAY IS AMONG OTHER
THINGS THE POLICIES SET
FORTH BY THE SECRETARY OF
DEFENSE STATE THAT
TRANSGENDER PERSONS WITH A
HISTORY OF DIAGNOSIS OF
GENDER DISFORRIA,
INDIVIDUALS WHO THE POLICY
STATE MAY REQUIRE
SUBSTANTIAL MEDICAL
TREATMENT INCLUDING
MEDICATIONS AND SURGERY ARE
DISQUALIFIED FROM MILITARY
SERVICE EXCEPT UNDER CERTAIN
LIMITED CIRCUMSTANCES
ACCORDING TO THE PRESIDENT
MEMORANDA.
DO YOU HAVE ANY REASON TO
BELIEVE THAT THE TIMING OF
THIS IS TO PLACATE THE BASE,
THAT'S THE CYNIC IN ME THEY
ARE THROWING THIS OUT ON A
FRIDAY NIGHT BECAUSE THE
BASE IS UP IN ARMS OR THIS
WAS PLANNED?
>> WELL, I MEAN, I THINK
THAT'S PROBABLY PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S GUT AND A LOT OF
PEOPLE AREN'T HAPPY WITH
PLAYING SOCIAL SCIENCE AT
ALL MAJOR INSTITUTIONS IN
THE COUNTRY RIGHT NOW.
THE PRIMARY THESIS IN THE
MILITARY IS NATIONAL
DEFENSE.
AND ALL THESE WE'RE JUST
DISTRACTED, THE DEMOCRATS
AREN'T SO HOT ON POLICY SO
THEY DO THIS IDENTITY STUFF
THROUGHOUT EVERY INSTITUTION
WE HAVE.
FBI IS BLOWN APART TOP 10
PEOPLE BEING EITHER FIRED OR
STEPPING DOWN OR LEAVING.
SO WE HAVE GOT TO GET BACK
TO BASIC BUSINESS, NOT
RUNNING TRILLION-DOLLAR
DEFICITS EVERY YEAR AS FAR
AS THE EYE CAN SEE.
>> Laura: SOCIAL ENGINEERING
IN THE MILITARY.
I THROW THAT IN THE MIX, WE
DON'T NEED TO DO THAT
ANYMORE.
FIGHTING FORCE.
WE NEED TO MAINTAIN A
AS FAR AS -- AS SOON AS THEY
ALLOW TRANSGENDERS TO GO IN
THE MILITARY JANUARY 1st
THE POLICY WENT IN EFFECT.
AS OF FEBRUARY 23RD, ONE
PERSON, ONE TRANSGENDERED
PERSON HAD SIGNED UP FOR
SERVICE.
GOD BLESS THE PERSON WHO DID